is a popular actor best known for his
role as spider-man tom holland has more
than 67 million followers on instagram
and more than seven million on twitter
but he hasn't posted that often until
recently when he made this announcement
i have taken a break from social media
for my mental health because i find
instagram and twitter to be over
stimulating to be
overwhelming i get caught up and i
spiral when i read things about me
online
and ultimately it's very detrimental to
my mental state
so i decided to take a step back and
delete the app
so holland feels this move is best for
his mental well-being which leads to the
question what is social media doing
overall for everyone else's mental
health here to talk more about that is
mental health therapist lakisha oliver
thanks so much lakisha for being here
thank you so much for having me it is
such a complex issue social media right
do the pros outweigh the cons i think it
really depends on the person right uh
you think of youth who consume a lot of
social media sometimes they believe
everything that they read and there's a
lot of unlearning that needs to happen
but the pros are that you can connect
with people maybe people that you
wouldn't connect with in your everyday
life so there are there is a balance in
that so tom holland made a decision a
personal decision for himself when might
others think okay it is time to at least
take a break if not step away i think
the best way to decide that is
determining how social media makes you
feel if everything on your feet is
negative if the comments are negative if
you're not feeling like they're it's
providing something positive in your
life then maybe it's time to step back
and it doesn't mean that you have to
step back forever it just means that
taking a break is not a bad thing and
even if the feed isn't negative
necessarily if you aren't in the best
space in your own life and everybody's
putting their best foot forward
understandably on social media you may
think uh everybody has it so much better
than i do this unrealistic view of what
life looks like right so you think that
everything is perfect in everybody
else's life and so i'm doing something
wrong because i'm struggling with
something the natural human existence
creates struggle there are things that
we deal with that aren't picture perfect
for instagram or social media that maybe
we don't get a realistic view of when
we're looking at social media is this
something that we should take into
consideration as to how often or how
much time we're spending on social media
is there a time window that is
appropriate so of course there are
people who say there are specific times
for age groups right that you should
limit
screen time for children however when
you're an adult sometimes those people
who are rolling over in their bed
scrolling through their social media not
getting sleep maybe being late for work
or being distracted at work when you
find that that's the issue then maybe
that's time to ask the question a unique
individual question of how much social
media should i consume yeah this is not
a right or wrong issue necessarily this
is layered for sure right as are
everything you know when it comes to
human beings right it's unique and it's
individual to the person and what works
best for you why has social media in
your opinion kind of taken that turn
into this political abyss where people
are expressing views be they radical on
one side or the other or mean-spirited i
think it's easy i think that you can
throw stones and hide your hands right
you can say whatever it is that you want
to say on social media and yes people
may comment on it but you put it out
there as a representation of who you are
and you can step away from it and now
it's out there you don't know how other
people will consume it or see it and
sometimes i think a lot of people lose
relationships and friendships over
things that they post on social media
just based on that idea i think that is
so true especially over the last
four or five maybe more years where
people have i've seen over and over
people saying well i'm blocking this
person because they said x yeah yeah
it's just not healthy in that respect so
how can we make sure that we are using
social media in a healthy fashion i
think it just goes back to the idea of
what are you using social media for
right are you using it for entertainment
and if you are then consume it as
entertainment don't make it a tangible
part of your life oh i'm so upset
because of what i read on social media
if you're using it to connect with
people then connect with people but
again it really goes back to the idea
that it's unique to the individual and
seeking affirmation is always dangerous
it's dangerous because you may get
affirmation but you also may get
negative responses and sometimes those
negative responses are what we
internalize and it makes us see
ourselves in a certain light lakisha
oliver thanks so much for your insight
appreciate you being here today thank
you jillian
thanks kendall those are